it's daybreak
and hector carrillo is on his way to
milk his cows
he follows a path up the nambiugua a
mountain in the la sepultura biosphere
reserve in southern mexico
legend has it that anyone who tries to
take something away from the mountain
will never return home
[Applause]
the slopes are shrouded in an almost
primal mist
there's been widespread deforestation on
many of the other mountain slopes in the
region
farmers keep their cattle in the forests
that remain
hector carillo's cows graze on land
that's fenced off to protect the
woodland
wreak havoc in the forest they destroy
everything contaminate the streams
and cause ground erosion so if they run
around the forest and it rains
there'll be landslides
hector keeps 20 cows he used to have
many more but he got rid of half of them
because he knows that traditional
livestock farming is bad for the
environment
decades ago his grandfather switched
from growing corn and beans to livestock
farming
because it was more profitable
three years ago hector joined the
project bio pasos
which promotes cattle farming that's
sustainable and doesn't destroy
diversity
his income is starting to increase and
the environment is gradually recovering
but it's been a difficult few years
but i asked him to give me a chance
when i took the risk of my small farm i
went through some hard times
very hard times i milked my cows
constantly but the yields were low
indigenous farmers traditionally let
their livestock graze in forest pastures
and also grew vegetables their methods
were sustainable
their expertise had largely been lost
now their descendants are looking to
revive it and save the cloud forest
jose antonio jimenez coordinates the bio
pasos project in the state of chiapas
meticulous planning facilitates the
farmers switch to the climate smart
livestock concept
jimenez knows the region well and can
provide practical support when necessary
the biggest challenge he faces is
convincing the farmers to
change the way they've always done
things
we need to work with the farmers to
identify problems together
we also need to work with them to find
solutions
this process taking into account the
expertise and experience of the farmers
and their families
helps them to learn new things we must
always factor in what the farmers know
protection through production that's the
motto of bio pasos
farming practices don't have to entail
forest degradation
some 1 200 farmers in the region have
joined the initiative
most of them are cattle farmers
[Applause]
juan pimentel still has a herd of cows
but he's also cultivating bananas and
soursop trees on a section of his land
even though it'll be five years before
the fruit provides him with a solid
income
he signed up with bio pasos
people think we're crazy they don't know
why we're planting small trees when we
won't even live to see them grow
but my wife and i hope that even if we
never get to harvest the fruit
one day our children and our
grandchildren will benefit
and they'll also benefit from improved
air quality
a year ago juan pimentel's wife julieta
was one of several local women in the
village los angeles
to found their own cheese dairy which
they run as a cooperative
they all used to make cheese at home by
themselves
now they've joined forces
the equipment is all brand new and was
provided by b
o pasos the women produce
five varieties of cheese
we women talk a lot we say what we think
it's good that we're making different
kinds of cheese
everyone knows different varieties so
we're experimenting
we women support one another
the farming families used to sell their
milk via a middleman
at a very low price now they're earning
better
that was one of the main incentives for
joining the project
and switching to sustainable production
it allows them to diversify it means
they can sell their produce at higher
our prices was not only to teach them
new technical skills but to support them
in the whole production chain
from the farm to the consumer
hector and rosa carrillo have also
invested in a cheese
press it's helped speed up the
production process
and they hope that in the long run it
will secure them a steady income
you